when you were working on conan part of
your
desire was to be anti-letterman in the
sense that not that you didn't love dave
but you had to do something different
and so because we love
dave that we wanted to be anti-letterman
what does it mean to be anti-letterman
that show
like my first interest in doing the show
that followed
johnny carson was when uh you know
because letterman was moving to cbs and
lauren had control of that time slot
after letterman was gone
and dana carvey was the first person
lauren wanted
and the network wanted and that would
have been a no-brainer
me and dana carvey wrote together all
the time on saturday night live
and i just had all these thoughts of
like oh we'll do like
sketch comedy we'll we'll bring sketch
comedy to late night
kind of like what steve allen did in the
50s he would like
interview people and character that's
what i thought we would do
with dana carvey except that he'd
probably have a sidekick interviewing
him and
but but it's like we would just do
sketches and like jimmy fallon kind of
many years later
did a lot of that but we did some of it
on conan you know
when conan got the gig those those ideas
in my head remained and i
i sort of imposed them on the show in
kind of weirder ways because conan and i
bonded in doing kind of surreal
absurdist stuff so
instead of interviewing celebrities like
actors dressed as celebrities we did
this thing with the photograph
of like bill clinton and we'd cut out
his mouth and
and i would usually be the guy doing the
impression the shitty impression of bill
clinton or
whoever bob you met conan at
saturday night live at snl yeah and you
said they said i didn't know this about
conan was you in your opinion maybe the
funniest guy in the room
at saturday night live as a writer like
he's back like him and jim downey were
probably the two guys who could make
everybody laugh
yeah was does that mean you're a great
sketch writer if you're the funniest guy
in the room
because some people don't translate no
it doesn't necessarily translate in
cohen's case he was a great sketch
writer
absolutely great sketch writer and super
fun to write with
like what really stuck out with him is
that he could make any scene
better like if i had an idea and conan
liked the idea and wanted to ride it
with me i knew
that you know it was going to be funnier